so web dot XML defines configurations
for web apps lots of web apps use web
dot XML not just App Engine apps and not
just maven projects so pom dot XML is
for your maven dependencies in your
maven project in pom dot XML you can
list all the dependencies for your
project like which version of j-unit
which version of App Engine SDK you want
and when you compile your project maven
will automatically get all the
dependencies for it an app engine - web
dot XML is where you configure things
specific to App Engine so App Engine can
fix here and there are more XML files
specific to App Engine such as Q dot XML
cron dot XML and you're going to be
learning about those as you work through
the course